[Music]
so time then for the press preview it's
our first look at what is on the front
of saturday's papers it's time to check
out the headlines tonight with the daily
mirror economy susie boniface and the
former conservative special adviser
anita boten they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight great to see
you both on this very hot evening we'll
chat in a second after we've had a look
at the front pages for you starting with
the i which declares race is on sunac
starts tory leader scramble
the guardian keeping it simple
proclaiming let battle begin
and the times highlights mr sunax
campaign launch video in which he told
prospective voters not to believe what
he called the fairy tale of higher
spending and lower taxes being able to
coexist
on to the telegraph quoting a
description of mr sunak as the serious
candidate
the ft hears that the former chancellor
is being accused of treachery by allies
of boris johnson who claim his
resignation on tuesday night was a
deliberate precursor to launching his
campaign today
there are more accusations of skull
duggary in the mail which says that
voters in northern red wall
constituencies are angry with many of
their mps for turning against mr johnson
the mirror reports on the very sad
untimely death of catholic priest father
dermott donnelly who was the brother of
the tv presenter dec
and father donnelly's passing is also on
the front of the
sun and don't forget by scanning the qr
code that you can see on screen joining
the program that you can check out the
front pages of the papers while you
watch us discussing them and as i say
i'm joined tonight by suzy boniface and
anita boten great to see you both this
evening thank you very much for for
joining us and um perhaps susie we can
start by just reflecting on what what an
incredible week it's been
has it only been a week it feels like
about a century since monday came around
really does doesn't it um and we're
looking at the front of the guardian
susie uh their headline very simple sums
it up doesn't it let battle begin
yep so all the tories running runners
and runs basically they all seem to be
going for it now
um and the fundamental problem we're
going to probably discuss this later on
but the fundamental problem is in the
conservative party you've got um a large
number of people who were on the front
benches who want to crack at it you've
got a lot of people who are kept out of
the limelight on the back benches they
want to crack at it people who want a
job in government are going for the
leadership in order that their support
could be picked off by a contender and
they get offered a job in order to back
their campaign later on and the
fundamental issue is that because boris
johnson for better or worse was such a
massive character
and such a um
he kind of became a black hole he sort
of had his own gravitational mass he
sort of sucked the rest of the
conservative party in if you like and no
one else had the heat or the light or
the oxygen that they needed to grow and
to form a base of their own or to become
rivals to him potentially and that
worked in his favor but now the
conservative party needs a new leader
they don't have very many to choose from
he's got these little teeny tiny little
saplings that have never really dipped
their toes in the water and we've seen
it today with rishi students supposedly
having this like you know slick pr video
he sounds like he's doing a cbeebies
bedtime story
i'll tell you a fairy tale but rishi is
ready to govern do you solid
so yeah it doesn't sound like you're
ready for rishi um susie um anita let's
have a look at the front page of the i
uh same theme really race is on sunac
starts tory leader scramble um a few
have already put their hats into the
ring uh more to come i mean do you think
anyone on the list does have the
personality to to pull this off
obviously we've got we've got rishi
sunat tom tugan hart sweller brotherman
and nadeem zahawi ben wallace he's the
book his favorite at the moment
i think these are all enormous uh
personalities who have um a lot to offer
the party and i've got to say i'm quite
excited about the variety of candidates
both in terms of their background their
ethnicities their gender i mean labor
could only hope to have such a diverse
slate of potential um prime ministers um
and i think that boris johnson obviously
was a huge and and will continue to be a
huge figure in the conservative party
but the fact that cabinets which are by
nature pretty anonymous for most people
that don't spend their time watching um
political press preview programs um
the the the fact that some of them like
rishi sunak has such significant
profiles i think stands them in good
stead for this election contest well
it's interesting that we were in
cheshire anita today interviewing uh
conservative voters interviewing
conservative party members as well and
at least one of them said to us well uh
he's going to he's going to back whoever
boris backs um and he's pretty angry at
what's happened
well yeah certainly i think that you
know you've got sort of um the front
page of the the mail that's reporting
kind of similar sentiments about the
feeling that boris johnson was not
afforded courtesy and these things are
never nice regicide never is um but i
think the conservative party is very
good at moving on in general we're
pretty ruthless about wanting to be
electorally viable and i think the prime
minister boris johnson you can clearly
see a sense that there are some
recriminations and some some um disquiet
amongst his supporters but i think that
boris johnson um you know it's only been
you know i can't even remember a day two
days since his um resignation
and as such i think the party will with
with the support of boris johnson be
able to move on to being fulsomely
behind the new prime minister yeah i've
seen yeah tuesday evening wasn't it um
front of the daily mail susie as anita
uh mentioned there's a picture of uh
little rishi um
it hasn't changed much actually has he
um
and
of course um kierstarma today being told
by durham police that he won't
face uh any uh action on on beer gate
and as the mail says as he opens the
door to a coalition of chaos voters rage
over boris toppling um i mean that
what what what do you make of this front
page
well i it's
listen i've always read the daily mail
very carefully i've worked for the daily
mail i've got a huge amount of respect
for most people that work there and it
was always been the first paper that i
ever read every morning because it was
sort of quite um definitive
in its production of news stories
whatever anyone might think about it and
in the last few weeks i've wondered
whether it's perhaps lost its finger on
the pulse of it
um because even tory voters and boris
and brexit voters i know just do not
quite chime with some of the stuff
that's been going on the front page
talking about the chaos that labour
might bring i think is a bit rich after
the week we've just had a little bit of
no chaos would be nice just for a while
um but it does seem as well although
they're already talking about tory
traitors and people who had you know
it's all getting up boris johnson and
everything else and feeding into this
sort of psychodrama that boris was
brought down this great giant by some
you know
subterfuge by others no one made him lie
all right no one has ever made anybody
lie unless they had a gun to their head
so this is literally this is a
self-inflicted defeat to what's happened
to boris johnson unfortunately um but
now it seems that what's happening is
there's loads of briefing coming out
from number 10 and although he's being a
caretaker prime minister he is
absolutely not going with any support
for his party to find the next leader or
anything or let him get on with it or
anything like that he's already briefing
he doesn't like this person he doesn't
like that one and this one's a traitor
and so-and-so's a snake it's going to be
vicious because boris didn't want to go
and he uh blames those people around him
for making him have to go because they
will resign so they're all gonna be a
traitor until even after boris leaves
he's gonna be doing this from the
sidelines he thought theresa may on the
back benches was causing trouble wait
till boris get up
well anita i mean how long do you think
he will remain in post um we know the
the 1922 uh committee new personnel on
monday will they speed up his exit do
you think
well i think it's widely expected that
uh between the 22 and the the party
chairman who will sort of set out the
next stage after the candidates whittled
down to two that this will be a sort of
early to mid-september um resolution and
obviously that will be confirmed on
monday it's clear that the party knows
that this is not about electing an
opposition leader um you know that's
something that labour has a privilege of
enjoying this is about electing prime
minister and you want to have direction
and focus as quickly as possible i
personally actually would like to see a
longer contest because i think that
there are lots of big questions for the
party to answer but nevertheless i think
from monday we can to expect to see
possibly sort of maximum two-week
process um where the candidates are
whittled down from what we suspect might
be at the moment ambitions of probably
40 but realistically about a dozen down
to um two by the 21st of july
susie do you think this way i'll just
have a look at the front of the times
actually don't listen to fairy tales
soon act tells tory voters from that uh
that video that you didn't like very
much i mean do you think this race will
come down to
low taxation versus belt tightening the
very issue that caused the rift of
course between uh sunak and boris
johnson
well we're already seeing some of the
candidates talking about how they're
going to be bringing immediate tax cuts
that's one of their sales and that's
probably going to play quite well with
the tory membership who of course are
going to be deciding our next prime
minister
i don't know whether rishi's
um suggestion that i'm not going to cut
any taxes because that's just more
responsible we have to just keep doing
what we are doing and you can't make me
do it
i don't think that's gonna it might work
in a general election kind of uh
situation it might work when you are an
existing chancellor and you're trying to
show fiscal strength and and you know
the longer view and stuff i don't think
it's going to work with this electorate
these 200 000 people who really really
really want to vote for tax cuts if if
someone's going to come along and give
them the red meat that they want they've
they've got to offer tax cuts really and
i think when she's gonna shot himself in
the foot a bit by saying that under him
there won't be any because these 200 000
people they've really not liked the high
taxes that he's imposed he can blame
boris that if he wants but he's got to
bring in some kind of tax cut because
everyone else is going to be doing that
if he doesn't he's lost elite
well i just don't think that's what
rishi sunax saying he's saying you can't
have both right the cake-ism that he
feels has been too long a discussion in
the party where you have your cake and
you eat it just isn't possible so what
he's saying is a fairy tale is
like high levels of spending and low tax
it's that dynamic that i think he's
seeking to challenge in order to kind of
say to the party like come on let's have
a mature discussion about what sounds
good the ship of our economy is so i
mean the chancellor i'm sorry the former
chancellor now has made no secret of his
ambitions to cut taxes he simply also
made no secret of the fact that he
doesn't want to keep adding and adding
to the deficit at a time where the
economy is increasingly uncertain and i
think it's that kind of nuance i think
is interesting and should be part of the
conversation throughout the leadership
contest okay and uh susan we'll just
finish with that with the mirror um
inside the mirror uh
and uh the paper has been asking red
wall voters which tory hopefuls they
recognize they do actually know who
rishi sunak is he was the most
recognised followed by sajid javid and
foreign secretary liz trust but nobody
could name attorney general zweller
brother man brexit enthusiast steve
baker although we know he's actually not
standing he's saying that he's
supporting uh rishi soon after all
senator dean zahari penny morden defense
secretary ben wallace um never heard of
him
no so this is erdlington in south
yorkshire a seat that was labour for a
very long time went to the tories in
2019. this is somewhere where despite
the fact that you know the the london
bubble does tend to say that oh people
elsewhere don't hear about this they
don't think about this there are plenty
of people in the country who watch the
news who listen to this i get stopped in
garden centers sometimes by someone who
saw me on the press review last night
and wants to talk about it at length
it be people do know and do care and if
they still don't know who some of these
people are then there's a huge issue
there also i don't know how many of the
two hundred thousand who'll be making
these choices are going to be in the red
wool seats because although people may
have voted for boris and the
conservatives in 2019 did they join the
party that's a different issue i think
because you know are the red wallers
going to be choosing the next prime
minister for us in the way they chose
the last one
or is the next prime minister going to
be chosen by the conservative base in
the south and the home counties and in
the slightly better off parts of the
world i think the latter is probably
more likely and so what people in
erdlington south yorkshire want is
probably not what the conservative party
is going to deliver them okay all right
we must leave it there for the moment
plenty more coming up after the break
including children told not to play in
the sun as the longest heat wave in
years arrives this weekend discussing
that more in a couple of minutes
[Music]
welcome back to the press preview susie
and anita still with us anita front of
the ft uh a cask of rare scotch has sold
for 16 million
pounds each bottle from this cask will
go for 36 000 quite incredible
i mean these are extraordinary sons of
money i happen not to be a fan of
whiskey particularly um but it's
incredible that this thing that is you
know a huge
export for us and kind of a great thing
that we're proud of and that we produced
in scotland
is um you know making these kinds of
waves in the rare whiskey's market
something i knew very little about and
continue to know very little about um
but but i mean imagine having 16 million
pounds to spend on
um but nevertheless quite a dramatic
story and i wonder if this is going to
be signs of um you know the rare whiskey
market continuing to boom through uh
tougher times and maybe people investing
in rare whiskey as a place to keep money
um um to keep their wealth as inflation
rockets i have no idea no i don't know i
mean for those of us uh you know um
for those sort of struggling with the
cost of living christ it all seems a bit
distasteful doesn't it um let's finish
let's finish with this story susie um
about the uh heatwave we're gonna have
some really hot weather coming up i have
my feet in the paddling pool today i
shall be doing it again i'm sure over
the weekend
yeah it's gonna be absolutely roasting
and people are quite wisely pointing out
that this isn't just a bit of summer and
a bit of hot sunshine like we used to it
can kill people
and we also have in this country a bit
of a problem with very humid heat
because of uh the moisture and so on and
the plants around us that will get us
released as well which means there's
less oxygen which causes other problems
and then so they're just advising that
um children should be playing out
between 11 and 3 when it's hottest
and they should be cooling off obviously
and making sure perhaps ringing around
and making sure your elderly relatives
are having six glasses of water a day
just to keep an eye on people because it
can people tend to think it's just an
opportunity to go out and you know have
a drink lie on the grass but people can
die and it is quite serious and we're
not used to this kind of heat in this
country for this long